okay we're live right okay
good afternoon good evening everybody to
members and officers of the council
members of the public and welcome to the
meeting of the standards committee
prior to the meeting all participants
have checked that they can be heard and
seen
and can see and hear other members and
it's vital that you can be heard and if
it is preferred that cameras are kept on
throughout the meeting just to double
check this and introduce everybody
present
kindly ask you to confirm your
attendance counselor braywood
council of bay bayford
sorry who is that counselor bayford oh
that's me yes
see you okay councillor christendom
uh yes i'm here thank you
thank you council of dexter here mr
chairman
council of duckworth
council of fellows
scoby
of bray wood
so i make that three absentees at the
present time
independent members patricia closer
patricia can you hear me she's on mutual
patricia can you unmute your machine
please
are we move on and council peter lorenzo
i'm here
yep i'm here chair thank you and i
noticed counselor crittenden has just
joined us
and then there's myself
uh chair can i just request that when
you refer to myself council clinton
or councilman that we use first names as
well because we do get a bit muddled up
yeah certainly helen no problem at all
thank you
chair councillor crowe brown as well
yeah thank you councillor program mr use
obviously they would not worry about
those attendees
if you have any technical difficulties
during the meeting then contact the
democratic
services officer on call who hopefully
will be able to assist you
and today that is james and their
numbers added to the chat box for this
meeting
i would ask that all participants mute
your microphone when you are not
speaking
this minimizes background noise and will
help everybody in listening to
proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
indicate on the chat to the right hand
side of your screen
i'll make a note of it and come back to
you once the person speaking is finished
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public
except for any items of business where
exempt or confidence that
confidentialization is considered
following the exclusion of the press of
the public from the meeting
this meeting has also been recorded and
will be broadcast on the internet
with everybody present please ensure
your mobile phones are turned to silent
and they are not used to make or receive
calls whilst the meeting is in progress
do not turn your phone off as it will
make it harder for democratic services
to contact you
should they need to and please refrain
from checking your emails or conduct
another business
and ensure you're in a quiet room that's
free from distractions
are there any apologies from absence
have we not heard from council the
brainwood council of duckworth or
councillor scoby
i haven't heard from them okay
i move that the minutes of the meeting
held on the 18th of november be
approved and signed as a correct record
could i have a second
please second dead council helen
crittenden
thank you unless anyone objects
we take those minutes of the meeting as
agreed
thank you are there any declarations of
interest
no good the next item on the agenda is
my report which i'm sure you've all had
a copy of and read
before the meeting so i can't see any
point in me going over it
has anybody got any questions they wish
to raise in respect of that
no that's good
now we're going into the agenda item
five which i think mr hughes
wishes to um speak on mr hughes could i
ask you to
open the matter concerning this report
you chairman
can you hear me yes yes
yeah sorry apologies my uh my internet
is
not particularly brilliant tonight
unfortunately um so if i do drop
out then somebody will just give me a
shout and i can
kind of come back in again so um
yes tonight we're looking at the report
regarding the recommendations from the
constitution of the working party
that's regarding changes to the way that
members of the public ask questions
at council meetings so members will be
aware that this report
went to or administration this report
went to full council in december
but at that meeting it was decided that
um
members would like uh the constitutional
new working party and standards to
look again at uh potentially including
some form of appeals process
to counsel the question of are
fundamental public and
and councillors um and also um
to um
to look at an appeals process
and uh sorry there was uh dude my
internet is
ready um asking a supplemental question
now uh these two issues were both uh
raised
at the constitutional working party some
weeks ago
and their view was that um
they did not feel that there was um any
need for an instruction of an appeals
process for rejected questions
but they did ask that the standards
committee discussed further whether to
allow
members of the public to ask
supplementary questions uh they also as
an aside to that also
asked whether or not the chief executive
when they
when she rejects the question that she
should consult
with the chairman of the council first
before doing so
and lastly that information on the
processes for submitting questions and
support
available from democratic services is uh
share both
full council and social media to help
members of the public
uh be better informed about how to ask
questions
loads of recommendations from the report
i'll quickly go through
some of the findings that we've done in
the preparation of this report both for
this committee against the
the constitutional reworking party so
with regards to supplementary questions
we democratic servants looked at all of
the different councils in kent
and the 12 councils in kent uh inclusive
of
planet five councillors five councils
allow members of the public to ask
supplementary questions uh and seven
don't
and of those five um it was unanimous
that they have to
uh the supplemental question has to
relate back
to the original question asked just like
uh our
members questions do at the moment and
that the chair and council has the
ability to reject
or disallow any questions that don't
follow those rules also
um it's um also something that we felt
that
uh he also has the power to uh try and
convince the member of the public to
avoid simply
having a reaction to the questions that
may or may not have been asked by the
cabinet member
um and to actually frame that
supplementary question
as a question rather than purely just as
a comment
with regards to time scales we think
that it would probably be best to
mirror the um uh current uh
supplementary question rules we have for
councillors um
and i think we just need to be mindful
of that the
amount of time that we have to ask
questions so that's a 30 minute time
limit
if we are going to add um
the ability for members to uh or maybe
the public to have supplementary
questions
obviously that's going to increase the
amount of time each individual member of
the public
has overall been asking their question
and that could actually have
the opposite effect of what people have
in mind which is obviously to increase
transparency
because that will actually reduce the
amount of time overall and so the number
of people
that will get the opportunity to ask
questions
that's just bearing that in mind
especially as we've increased the
or we are due to increase the uh
word limit question from 50 to 150
so that is the um the supplementary
questions element of it
with regards to the right of appeal
we've looked again we looked at all the
councils in canton of the twelve
no council in kent has any form of
appeals process
against rejected question um
i think from democratic services point
of view certainly
there will be a significant
administrative burden for us to be able
to do that
um the way council questions are asked
at the moment
is that most questions are received on
the day of the deadline
and obviously that then makes any
appeals process
have to happen in the very short amount
of time between
the well it's the five working days that
we have between
the um closure of the questions deadline
and the actual meeting itself um
when would the deadline appeal be
because again obviously
there's only five days so that needs a
very short amount of time
and if you're going to have a period of
time for an allowance and appeal
um then there'll be the time that it
takes to determine that appeal
and then if that is a appeal is
successful then that leaves very very
little time
for anybody to write a response to the
question that's being asked
again another thing we need to say is
actually well who would
who would be considering that field
um persons are already considered and
approved
or rejected against the criteria by the
chief executive
so again there's that question and also
what is the basis for an appeal
um again questions that are over the
word limit
for example are very easily
rejected um because it's clear that it's
very
black and white issue of is it more than
what will be 150 words
or not um whereas it then becomes more
nuanced with the
um should a question be considered
vexatious or should it be uh too similar
that then becomes again a much more
difficult question to answer again
in a very very short amount of time
we did do some research as to the number
of questions that we've received over
the past year so since january the 1st
we've received 34 questions from
republican councillors 27 of which were
accepted
those seven were rejected uh of those
seven
three were regarding ongoing planning
applications three were vexatious and
one was deemed to be substantially
similar to one that we've already
received
in the last six months so given the fact
that
actually that's not a large amount so
um the rejected the
ones regarding planning applications and
the ones regarding
um substantially similar um
generally are quite uh i got this wrong
before
objective yeah
in the sense that is quite a black and
white choice
um whereas the more subjective
uh being the vexatious one that's only
three
out of the 34 questions that have been
asked so that doesn't really suggest
that there's a substantial amount of
questions being rejected
that would then require us to have an
appeals process
and also the last thing i'd like to say
is that actually
um democratic services are always
welcome we always welcome people getting
in touch with us
before the deadline to ask about the
question itself
uh we will help members of the public to
uh draft questions
and build questions and we can check
questions for you um part of the part of
the issue that we have
is that for whatever reason members of
the public and councillors
will leave questions or submitting your
questions to the last minute
now i'm not going to go into why that
happens but obviously
one of the implications of that
happening is that if a question is
rejected
we will always try and work with a
member of the public to help them
rewrite their question in a way that it
can be asked
but that's not possible 10 minutes
before the deadline finishes
if somebody had decided to submit a
question a week in advance
then there's plenty of time for us to be
able to work with that person
and assist them in getting a question
that is actually acceptable
so that's just something else to bear in
mind so
um the only thing i would like to add is
that
at the end of the discussion um and
um irrespective of what uh the panel
agrees with
uh the um
the supplementary questions element of
it and or the
um appeals process uh the panel will
have to still make a recommendation
regarding the word limit
uh being increased from 50 to 150. i'm
not going to go into that
today because that's already been
through the process
um before when he got to the council
meeting in december
and no member at that point said there
was any issue
with that particular thing but because
it wasn't agreed at the council meeting
it will need to be subsequently agreed
at the next council meeting so it's
still really important that we make a
recommendation about that so please
don't forget that element of it
um and that's all gentlemen
i think thank you miss hughes i think
members we can take it
stage by stage has anybody got any views
on the right to appeal decision
council fellows
i mean i i don't think there should be
an appeals place i think nick laid it
out uh fair and square there that day
um i mean you're going to end up with
the vexatious people just keep
submitting
awkward questions every every month
month after month you know and then
bogging down
the democratic service officers i think
that the appeals process uh is
is not a void i think the um the ability
for a
chairman of the council to um look at
rejected questions i think is suitable
enough i think in my opinion
okay counter helen clinton
uh yes i wanted to ask one question uh
regarding um
those that are rejected is the reason
for the rejection
given to the person that put in the um
question in the first place are they
made aware that their
uh question was considered vexatious for
example
perhaps i could ask mr used to answer
that
uh through youtube yes it is yes we
always respond to them via email to say
that
sorry your question is too long or it's
been vexatious because
or um for example it may be that they've
mentioned an officer by name for example
but we've already given the reason
councillor baker thank you chair uh yes
i agree that there shouldn't be an
appeals process
because i feel that um
members of the public wanting to ask
questions know in advance of the
criteria
and i think it it would mean that fewer
people were
able to to ask their questions simply
because of the time limit so
i don't think it should be considered
okay
thank you i don't think anybody else has
got any comments
by the looks of it mr use can i ask do
we have to
sorry counselor cup thank you chad i
just wanted to quickly make a
quick comment yeah i agree that we don't
need the the appeals
process in place i think um as mr user
said there
if anything is submitted that um isn't
then taken forward
they can always uh get the help from the
democratic services
in in how to construct a question that
is actually helpful
not just to themselves but also to the
council as well so i i think that an
appeals process
is not necessary at all thank you chair
thank you mr hughes can we break this
down into four
recommendations with proposers and
seconders
if you want to do that chair that's
absolutely fine yeah i just think it
would be a lot easier
rather than trying to lump it all
together that was all
so i think the proposal is from the
committee
is that we do not recommend an appeals
process
for rejected questions could i have a
second please
oh second that counts the cup i think it
counts for the cup
right if we can move on to the second
item of that
that the standards committee allow
members of the public to ask
supplemented questions has anybody got
any views on that
i have a question yes helen
um when you were when we were having the
introduction
from nick hughes just now um it was
talking about the time limit of 30
minutes
how many questions if we allow
supplementary questions
um how many questions are we likely to
lose
off the end of those who had put in a
question
um for example i suppose what i'm really
asking is how often do we fill the 30
minutes
um and what kind of impact would that
have on the number of questions
um that actually typically get asked to
counsel
mr hughes
um we
it's quite a difficult one to answer
some sometimes
we have lots so we've had 10 10 plus
questions
uh at a couple of meetings but equally
then we'll have a meeting that only goes
by
with two for example like the last
council meeting we only had two
questions
um but uh sometimes we have lots um
i think we will see an impact it is
difficult to tell because
i think that's quite uh because
obviously we're going to increase the
word limit
that will allow for a couple of extra
minutes per person
and so they'll have like a three minute
speech to do their question with
i would imagine you'll then have a
two-minute answer from a mum
a member of the public plus the minute
to ask the supplementary questions
you're looking at probably
an extra three or four minutes per
person
now that doesn't sound a lot but um
and a lot to be fair it does depend upon
how quickly the chairman
goes through it um and um
again that's quite difficult in in a
online meeting
it happens a lot quicker if you think
about it
you can click straight from one person
to another to another
whereas in the in the council chamber
they've got to actually walk from the
public gallery
up to the after the bench ask the
question walk back down again
um and so it's quite difficult to tell i
think
i think it will have an impact i would
imagine that
in a 30 minute session you may look to
lose one
one person or two people at bush
depending upon
if we were really busy i mean hopefully
most weeks it won't make a difference
but on the weeks when it's really busy
then i think yes
we would probably have to cut down the
number of
people uh asking questions um
the chairman obviously does have the
provision extend out beyond the 30
minutes
but that's quite unusual i mean
the idea being is that there is a 30
minute
limit for a reason so it's quite unusual
for him to
go past that i hope that's helpful
thank you can i just make one
observation on that mr using
surely we would know before the meeting
how many questions are going to be asked
so the questioner can be told
that the one that they've got because
they're running out of time
would automatically be passed on to the
next council meeting
so it wouldn't look as if it's been
rejected
i think we will always uh the process
that we normally follow chair is that we
will always put all the questions that
we receive
into the agenda and if we can get
through everybody
then brilliant that's fantastic any
questions
that we don't get to when the 30-minute
envelope effectively closes um
can either be answered in writing or as
you say will be rolled over
they wouldn't be rejected per se that
they would be
then become the first in line for the
next meeting
um but i think it's more the the fact
that
if you get as far as getting in a
question in the agenda
you would want it to be arted
um rather than being rolled over to the
next meeting
okay thank you i i've only got one
observation as i raised at the
constitutional review working party
having been sitting in the council
chamber and a member of the public goes
up to ask for the question
the question the question is then
answered but the poor member of the
public is sitting there
not knowing what to do next so i'm i am
in favor of supplementary questions
has anybody else got any views on this
council helen crittenden
um i wanted to agree with a comment
about the the
increase in the word limit um and
uh that already allows for additional
elements to the
original question and i noted
in the report some of the comments about
concern about
using that second question or
supplementary question
to disagree or become vexatious
and those are the things that concern me
um and i'm
disinclined to um agree with
supplementary questions
okay thank you cancer fellows yeah i
mean i'm against it really i mean i'm
obviously i'm not a cabinet member so
i'm not really in a firing line for
public questions but
generally they're quite obscure off the
wall questions where
the a pre-prepared statement has to be
issued by an officer
as a response to the question and a
supplementary question he's just going
to try and catch someone out on
a subject that they're probably not even
going to know the answer to anyway so i
think that
it's it's a no for me okay has anybody
else got any observations
i do chair cancer cup yes counselor cup
uh very much uh in support with
counseling good skin and also counsellor
fellows as well
um just on the terms that i i think that
there is there's no need for a
supplementary question uh when we are
looking to extend the word limit on
these questions
because that will surely allow the
member of public to have more
clarification within their question
to a certain cabinet member um and
then there is that fear that if we allow
them to have that supplementary question
it allows them to have the opportunity
to make a a personal attack upon
someone whether that may be a member of
the council or even
an officer and i don't think that we
want that
um cause of possibly embarrassment to
happen for the council
and for ourselves as councillors okay
thank you council bayford
thank you chair yes i agree with
everything that's been said and i think
that um
allowing supplementary questions as well
as the additional
uh word limit what could make questions
uncontrollable really okay thank you
counselor dexter
yes i i must ask to support my
colleagues on this
i don't think supplementary questions
are necessary
and of course a lot of supplementary
questions
um turn out as statements
thank you thank you councillor whitehead
has joined the meeting
i understand she's entitled to ask a
question under 20.1 is that right mr
hughes
yes the if the panel is happy to um
so councillor whitehead wishes to speak
on 20.1
if the panel are happy to do so then and
she's
entitled to a question yeah that's fine
by me
yeah absolutely fine councillor
whitehead could you then ask
what is it your comment uh thank you
that very much
for letting me speak um
in relation to this issue i understand
the potential complications of the
supplementary question um
in terms of things being potentially
vexatious i would hope
that the chair would be able to deal
with anything
that would come in that sense
but i do feel in terms of democratic
participation which is what the council
is
supposed to be for supplementary
questions
could greatly increase people's
understanding of what we do
and obviously i do get a great deal of
questions as a cabinet member
i'm more than happy to answer any
supplementary questions
and i think it shows that as a council
we do
want to engage fully we do want to be as
open as possible
so i can understand the difficulties
involved both in terms of
time extension but council is our public
face
it's where we get to show that we want
to fully engage with the public so for
me the
point of supplementary questions is
quite important
and
within my portfolio in that aspect i
would very much
support it thank you
thank you for your comment do any of the
independent members wish to make any
comments
counselor cup thank you chad i just
wanted to quickly make a comment on what
uh councillor white had said
i would very much be in the mind of
supporting
uh her comments but uh given that
we weren't looking at an extra uh word
limit for the questions but as the extra
word limit is coming into place i feel
as if that
that kind of covers the ground of the
possibility of a
supplementary question um allowing for
that further clarity and as has been
raised before
if you are a member of the public i feel
as if you would
go in with a certain question and then
that is up for
the cabinet members to to answer um and
i don't feel
that there is then the need for that
supplementary question to go on it
especially when you've got the extra
word count of the question thank you
chair thank you
mr peter lorenzo you wish to raise a
question
no it's not a question it's just a case
of um
i'm agreeing with you as chairman that
uh i will be in favor of the
supplementary
supplementary questions um yeah
it's uh it shows that the council is
will be very happy to actively listen
and answer questions
the the um the reputation the council
hasn't known it's not very good
let's uh let's encourage attention
fine thank you i don't think anybody
else
wishes to make any comments so can i
make a proposal
that the standards committee at this
stage recommend to the council
that they allow the public to ask
supplementary questions
first of all is there a seconder to that
proposal
no secondus or the proposals not i will
second that
mr lorenzo seconds that that i think mr
uses my right
thinking we should take a vote
yes right in that case
can we just go down the list
council of bayford for or against i'm
against supplementary questions
thank you council
helen clinton against
council of dexter against
against councillor
john quitting
where's he gone councillor crittenden
councillor crowe brown against chair
patricia causer
she's disappeared peter lorenzo
i'm for it thank you lee well brooke
uh against chair i'm for it but
the motion is lost so do we now need to
put a second proposal
mr hughes you can't do j yeah
again i think the second the second
proposal then from the standards
committee
is that we do not recommend
to the council that they allow for
supplementary questions from the public
is there a seconder yeah our second
lecture
fellows thank you all right council
david
four thank you
councillor ellen crittenden
counselor john quitting
for the program
patricia cosia she's disappeared i think
peter lorenzo against
lee well brooke four
and i am against but the second motion
is carried so
the recommendation to the full council
from the standards committee is that
we do not recommend that supplementary
questions be allowed from members of the
public
if we can move on to the third sorry
chair um
could i just check who proposed that
can i just check with nick that that's
all right that mr tucker proposed both
even though they're contradictory that's
fine
great thank you okay
no problem move up move on to item three
of that recommendation
that when the chief executive rejects a
question
they should first consult with the chair
of the council
does anybody wish to make any comment on
that
council the cup thank you chad i think
that
um i would support this uh proposal that
uh if
if the new executive wishes to refuse a
question they should be in consultation
with the chair of the council
um because i think just for that
security that there are two minds uh
looking over these questions
to assess whether or not it's actually
worth being read out
to to the full council and then to a
cabinet member
personally to me makes makes sense i
think that often in these situations two
minds are better than one
that's no offense of course to our chief
exec thank you chad
okay mr hughes
mr hughes thanks kevin um i would just
point out that
um uh obviously uh
is the the point that we made at the
constitution of the working party
that um if we uh
believe that we want to reject the
question i.e
um that we feel as if it is within uh
six months of the previous one we will
always
put that point of view forward to the
monitoring officer
and the monitoring officer then
obviously advises the executive
she doesn't do that in isolation
um there are there are a number of
people that will help
look at that and assess that question
before it's then
pushed to the the chief executive so
just to put that in the case
um and also um i think we would
uh there was a discussion with the crwp
about whether or not we wanted to
forward all questions
for example like if for example somebody
submitted a question and it was 151
words
then do you really need to send an email
to the chairman of council
saying this is 151 words we need to
reject it
um when clearly it's just too big um
absolutely agree that that maybe that
you want to consider
um consulting the chairman of council on
things about votatiousness and
substantially similar
but for the more basic things like
i would suggest that we maybe don't do
that
thank you very much councillor fellows
i just wanted to say i agree with
everything counselor cup said and i
believe that we should
uh definitely have a second opinion
thank you
council helen crittenden uh once again
i'd like to confirm i agree with what
councillor cup
said um i'd also like to add that as
we're recommending that we're not going
to allow appeals it would
uh give another layer of confidence um
at the first submission of the question
okay thank you does anybody else wish to
raise any comments
council bayford yes i i agree because i
think it removes
um subjective subjectivity particularly
um in relation to vexatious questions so
i think it
it's a good thing thank you so
i think then we can put a proposal and
i'll be looking for a second
that when the chief chief executive
considers requesting
rejecting a question they should also
consult with the chairman of the council
could i have a second please second it
helen council helen crittenden
thank you
can i take a vote on that council
bayford
for
for council the cup
for councillor john quitting
he's left well councillor of crowbarrow
four
patricia causia
peter lorenzo four
be well four
so four so that's carrick then that we
put that motion to the council
helen thank you for your comment there
that we didn't put a
take a vote on the first um
recommendation about the appeal i just
formed the opinion that every
where the conversations went everybody
was
in favor of not having an appeal but we
can put it there
if we need to
are you happy with that ellen uh yes i
am i can see
um the response from katie brewer as
well thank you
thank you right so perhaps then we can
move on to
number four and that's
this arose from what the comments we
made during the constitutional
review party uh about democratic
services assisting members of the public
with the wording of questions and it was
recommended that
this be mentioned at full council
meetings
and also on social media does anybody
wish to make any comment
councillor helen clinton just to support
the recommendation that's all
thank you any of the comments or can we
put the recommendation to the vote
the recommendation council baker
yes i i agree um as long as there's some
way of ensuring that the question isn't
leading
you know the the help given isn't
leading
yes i understand what you're saying so
the recommendation from the standards
committee is then that
democratic services should ensure that
publicity is given to the public
both at council meetings and through
social media
that they are available to assist
members of public
with the wording of questions to council
members
is there a secondary second
that's lecture fellow seconded it
can i take do we need to take a vote
or is everybody in agreement
everybody's in agreement fine that's
carried right so then we can move on to
the final item on the agenda which is
the
standard sorry mr used darren you forgot
the bit i told you not to forget
um
in that case one final recommendation
that the committee recommend to the
council
that the number of words
used by questions from members of the
public is increased to 150.
could i have a seconder please yeah i
second that chair
some fellows anybody against
no so that's good is that happy now mr
hughes
thank you chairman
right and now we come to this the
complaint statistics which i think
you've all seen
has anybody got any questions to raise
i shouldn't think so the only one i've
got which is mentioned in my report is
when
councillors write on social media but
that will be covered at the full council
meeting
is there any other business
no in that case the time is
6 15 and the meeting is closed and thank
you all for your attendance